Speaker 1: We've now been talking about Fox
News host Maria Bartiromo for some time.
She has gone from being a pretty good financial
reporter, the first woman to broadcast from
the floor of the New York Stock Exchange years
ago to a total Trump brownnosing sycophant
who repeats every bogus lie promoted by Trump
or the people around him.
She has promoted and signal boosted either
through guests or herself, just about every
absurd lie about the 2020 election.
And now she is defiantly telling us she will
not stop, Maria Bartiromo erupted on her own
show yesterday and says she will keep telling
lies.
She calls it the truth about the twenty twenty
election.
You just have to see this.
It's a profile in what I call ignorant courage.
The dynamics and the tone is of a principled
and defiant nature where she will not be silenced,
but from telling lie after lie after lie.
Let's take a look at this clip.
Speaker 4: Let me broaden this out.
And by the way, Dr. Cohen, we should point
out the effect that the litigious nature of
our system has on creating restraints on drug
claims.
That's another major problem.
But, Senator, this is just one of many lies.
Let's take a look at the biggest lies of all
since the Democrats came up with this ridiculous
buy about election integrity.
These are actually the biggest lies, the a
hoax based on a made up dossier.
Speaker 1: OK, so remember the Russia hoax
based on a made up dossier?
The dossier is made up in the sense that any
document is created.
She's saying the substance was made up.
I've seen no evidence of that.
I've seen corroboration of some elements of
the dossier and just not yet corroboration
of others.
But there's no evidence that it was made up.
And of course, Russia hoax.
And listen, dozens of indictments.
Mueller unable to clear Trump on obstruction.
Speaker 4: So ridiculous to try to take down
Trump and impeachment of Trump with absolutely
no crimes.
Speaker 1: Remember that?
That's that's another red herring.
Impeachment is a political process.
It doesn't require criminality under the law.
So it's a classic red herring
Speaker 4: attached to it.
The Hunter Biden laptop and all of his business
deals in the money that he receives from everybody
from the former Moscow mayor's wife to the
Chinese companies tied to the Chinese Communist
Party.
Speaker 1: OK, so there's no lie.
It's the right is upset that it didn't.
The right is upset that unsubstantiated claims
about Hunter didn't derail Biden's presidency,
but it to even have it on this list seems
strange.
Speaker 4: The origins of covid-19, a lab
leak and the trip.
Speaker 1: OK, and then, of course, and then
she says so notice, she says, as a as in passing,
that there's been a lie about the fact that
covid was a lab leak.
We don't know that to be true.
And I, like many others, have said, investigate
everything.
But let's not say something is likely until
we have reason to believe that by treatment.
I assume she's referring to hydroxy chloroquine.
And of course, the lie there was was from
the right course.
Speaker 4: There's the armed insurrection.
Armed insurrection is what Nancy Pelosi keeps
calling January 6th.
Senator, how many guns were actually taken
up on that day?
Speaker 1: OK, there were some guns.
We know that there were some guns since
Speaker 4: she says it was armed robbery.
But they always talk about thousands of armed
insurrectionist.
I asked the FBI witness not one not one gun
was recovered either in the Capitol or on
the Capitol grounds.
Speaker 1: Understand that recovered just
means they weren't left behind when
Speaker 4: that FBI witness.
Speaker 1: But there's video of people with
handguns.
Speaker 4: That's just one of the latest big
lies.
And, you know, Maria, we have to understand
how dangerous this is for our democracy.
Speaker 1: I'm concerned about her show is
dangerous for democracy,
Speaker 4: Russian interference in the 2016
2020 election.
What the big media does is so much more influential
and interfering in our election year electoral
process than anything.
Speaker 1: So Johnson's filibustering.
But now listen to what she says when they
go back to Maria or
Speaker 4: could ever hope to accomplish.
And they don't admit they'll never admit it.
I am so incredibly proud of this team on Sunday
morning futures and of working alongside you.
We have been telling every story.
We've been on the right side of it for seven
years, going I've been trashed every day along
the way.
Keep trashing me.
I'll keep telling the truth.
Speaker 1: A defiant and principled Maria
Bartiromo, who has not been on the right side
of even a single issue that I can remember
and telling us that she will keep telling
all of the lies.
What's the long game for Maria Bartiromo?
Is it that Trump comes back because while
he was president, I'm sure it was very cushy
and fun for her to have a friendly president
that she could access.
But what is the long game at this point in
time?
I have no idea.
Let me know if you have thoughts.
Make sure you're subscribed to the second
YouTube channel, YouTube dotcom slash Pakman
live new YouTube channel with totally different
content.
We'll take a quick break and be right back